Hey, welcome back to the $10 million studio.
I know it seems like we're changing all the time,
but actually we're just moving within the same room.
We're trying different ways of organizing the set to make it easier for you
guys. This is doubling right now as a screen, but actually look at this.
I can turn it off. Boom, boom. There's our board. Huh?
Not too shabby. And as you can see, moved into a new place,
there's an annoying guy. Next door. He's kind of snooping around,
which is kind of annoying. Ben cumberbun or something like that.
I don't know what his name is. He's always trailed by his fumbling side.
Kick out of it. I don't know what it's about. Cause they're kind of weird.
I don't know what their deal is, but nevertheless,
we're not going to let that stop us.
It's some good real estate for finding out the new mysteries of the internet
from digging up the scams from exposing the frauds.
So thank you for joining me on this journey. Now,
today we are reacting to fake gurus calling out fake gurus. And let me say,
I'm having trouble here seeing my future because I just invested in a
$10 billion studio to call out fake gurus.
And I'm going to be out of a job soon because I can't call out the fake gurus
faster than the fake gurus are calling out the vagaries. You won't believe it.
I never thought in a million years that the strategy of a fake guru would
be to call out fake gurus. I don't know what the idea there is.
Like do they not think we'll see through it?
Let's find out here's a few that I collected today for us to look at together.
So this is our first guy and I'm just going to say here,
I see this not as a video, but as actually an ad,
this guy is spending money to call out fake. It's insane.
Oh, this another online business group. I don't know about you,
but I'm getting pretty sick and tired of all of these fake online
business gurus. Trying to get me to this.
Guy. Watches copies of lot for sure. A hundred percent.
Get registered for their webinars guys. I know you've been seeing the ad,
but I promise you if you just give me 60 seconds.
Okay? So then you give them 60 seconds, right?
You got to give them 60 seconds and you think, Oh man,
he's not going to be like them. Right?
If you want to create a life, a better financial freedom,
live the life of your dreams and stop working a nine to five job.
Stop doing all this stuff that you hate. Click the link around this video.
Sorry. We already went onto the next one. Hopes you guys have been spoiled,
but let me just say that. I'll just say just, just one word about that last guy,
dude, you can't call out the gurus and then sell your webinar goats.
So your free trading RO come to my free training. Come to my free training.
Where so you on my course,
what a joke are more scams out there on the internet than
there are legitimate opportunities by far.
Okay. Let's check out this.
Cut to John [inaudible] selling scabs. Listen, let me say,
let me say this about, uh, let me say this about that thing.
Because I talked to John Crestani. I said,
how much did it cost to get Chris Hansen on your show? He said 25,
25 K to call out the gurus.
Now this itself was a scam because you were supposed to buy a book,
which is a $20 a month upsell for the book,
a book that costs has a $20 a month subscription attached to it. But yeah,
John, you just keep calling out the scammers buddy. Okay.
Let's check out this method to literally copy and paste ads to make money.
First off,
you don't want to run a business where you have to actually like buy products
and like ship them out to people. Okay?
So let's forget about e-commerce drop shipping.
I don't even know why I tried it.
These guys make such better comedy than I ever could with these things.
There are so many scams out there, but make bang. We're going to make bank,
sell my product, work for it,
search for my last name because the product we're going to be the product where
we're going to be selling.
It's actually my product selling is actually my product, unfortunately.
All right. Next beam. I don't know. That's beauty pie, right? No. Nevermind. Uh,
next guru.
I believe the world of e-commerce education is full of scammers pretenders and.
Okay, hold on. I want to pause there cause it's going to be funny later.
He's saying that the baller busters are calling out the scammers. Okay?
Remember that?
Right? Liars.
I'm sure you've seen their ads all over the place and I bet many of you have
even been their victims for all of you gurus and self-proclaimed experts out
there. You better watch out [inaudible].
Now when you go to bollard Buster's page,
remember this is the guy that's calling out the gurus,
the Kevin's Ang endorses Kevin's Ang is one of their calls, dude.
What is there? I am the show guy, little, a little,
little CoLab with baller busters, but this is a long call out.
I'll look, he's doing another e-commerce of 70% off.
That was the scammy did last time. Where am I headed?
And jail next year.
The stock market can be a very dangerous place. If you're following a fake,
if you're learning from a fake and because of this bull market,
there are lots of fakes in this video.
I'm going to talk about it and tell you how to expose a fake.
Ah, yes. Tim Sykes. The original huckster dude. Yes. So this video,
which is released recently called like calling out gurus or how to spot a fake
you're real. It's all just him pitching his million dollar challenge.
I want to get into my millionaire challenge and you're ready to be taught by a
drill Sergeant.
Now, one of my favorite things about Tim Sykes, the millionaire trader is that,
uh, he's got verified trades on a platform called profit dot L Y
or profitably. Now here's an interesting thing.
Who verified Tim Sykes traits. Well profitably, but who owns profitably?
Tim's hikes. That's right. Tim Sykes is verified. Tim Sykes trades.
You better not call him a scam, dude. Hey, they're verified, verified by him.
Okay. Next guru.
I see one more person on my Tik TOK timeline called professional advice because
Danny Devin thousands, or sometimes even knowing $2 in their Robin hood account,
I swear I'm going to rip out my hair. Okay. D you CA you shouldn't be.
Able to teach. If you just have a thousand or a million dollars in your account,
you're saying don't fall for all these fake Robinhood gurus. Okay.
So don't trust somebody just because they say they have millions of dollars in
their stock market account.
Got it. I made a million dollars in four weeks,
and this is exactly how I did it.
This is by the way, like several months later after he calls out the gurus, Oh,
don't listen to all those other idiot gurus. Hey, by the way,
I've made millions of dollars.
Start off with a thousand dollars, which I turned into 5,000, 5,000 to 10,000,
10,000 to 25,000, 25,000 to 50,000.
I believe at 50,000 into a million dollars. Hey,
and this is definitely not a demo account, not a demo account,
but I turned a thousand dollars into a million dollars. Totally. Uh, yeah,
this is very believable. Yeah. Just no big deal.
A hundred thousand percent returns, that's it? Hey,
a hundred thousand percent returns. What are you going to say?
I'm lying next scam.
Mindset. You're doing that. And you're trying to scam people.
You don't have to go down that path.
This is a Tik TOK person named 11, not working, but what does she say?
Scammers need right mindset. That's right. If you're scamming,
you got the wrong mindset.
Stay honest, stay true to yourself. You'll live a happier life.
You'll be able to sleep better at night. The good news is you can change,
but unfortunately, no, that's a decision.
Oh, okay. So yeah. All you fakers out there.
All you scammers do the right thing. Don't, you know, stop scamming people.
How to get from a thousand dollars to a million dollars.
Check out the link in my bio for more.
Oh, a little course. Action there. Little, a 2% theory.
Yeah, just a thousand dollars to a million dollars. Two years.
What's the big deal. Just trading crypto, baby. All right.
And that's basically it. Yeah.
I dunno what I'm going to do here on this channel.
All the gurus are calling out all the gurus. I don't really know what to do.
They're all saying, watch out for the vagaries as fake gurus.
I honestly don't know where my place is anymore. I'm lost. I'm confused.
Let me know what you think, guys. What do you think? Tell,
let me know what you think of the studio. Two guys, we're slowly,
we're building out our $10 million set. We're paying off the loan. Um,
it's a massive loan.
So if you haven't already go buy my fate guru spotter course for the low,
low price of $10 million or $69 million. If you get the flash sale,
which I'm only doing one time,
which is this very second to the left first 500 people to click the link below.
And, uh, that's basically it.
Don't forget to smash like and subscribe. Thank you.
[inaudible].